a call for silence
the rescue team just heard a voice
coming from under the rubble
they are working relentlessly here to
reach people buried below
one of them is my husband the other is
my son I already lost a child here and
my daughter-in-law they are dead
after nearly two hours the rescue team
managed to pull out 24 year old mehmed
Amin ergas
a moment of joy for his family and
everyone around
and I hope every
was found alive
[Music]
Muhammad remained buried under this
collapsed building for 58 hours
and now it's time to rescue his father
there are dozens of people still under
the rubble here
some of them are still alive
their families wait anxiously but hopes
are fading with every passing minute
the scale of Destruction is immense
Turkish president erdogan visited
affected areas promising more help
we are working together with a number of
Ministries including the environment and
City Planning Ministries who are working
with our social housing management who
will look into this our Target is to
rebuild in one year and we will start
construction of new houses in all those
10 cities to make sure nobody is without
a shelter it'll take some time to build
those buildings of course
authorities have set up this density now
it is home to hundreds of people
medical workers are at the front line
but it's not an easy job the hospitals
are already overwhelmed but injured and
dead keep arriving
nearly a thousand buildings have
collapsed and hundreds have died here
are frantic families still have hope and
they say they won't leave without
getting their relatives out from under
the rubble dead or alive
Southern turkey